so a woman was arrested because she
tried to stab a man after he got into a
dispute with her because she farted out
loud in a dollar store
farting in dollar store Wow so the dude
farted he farted wait that's a woman all
right she farted while she was in line
to pay at a dollar store the man right
next to her said something they got in
an argument she pulled out a knife from
her purse and made a motion where it
seemed like she was gonna try to stab
him and she said I'm going to gut you
but she ended up walking away and
leaving police officers found her legs
gonna have that you also can't trust a
person who's just gonna rip an open fart
at the dollar store in line you know
rude that is yeah but also maybe it's
somebody does fart I'm gonna go but I'm
not gonna call you out on it oh I will
if it's loud and like and cuz I'm the
big guys everyone thinks the big guy
fart I'll be like damn come on I'll go
come on man
you won't be like damn lady you just
fart in front of me but I'm like Jesus
at least make sure everyone knows it's
not me
I go Jesus Christ it smells like [ __ ] up
in here like I want everyone to know the
big guy didn't do it if she ripped one
right in front of you while you're in
London like you're like oh my god I
would laugh like umm were you born in a
[ __ ] Zoo the with the dollar store
sorry bad enough man
yeah it's every night I went to the
dollar store and I'm praising a bad mood
did the way of my mom's shop still get
sort of [ __ ] a lot of people it's
actually a good place to go if you want
to get cheap [ __ ]
yeah for a dollar yeah but also it's bad
enough you're there when it's lady in
line ripping farts near bill I'm playing
where someone keeps Florida yeah it
drives me crazy you don't saves that
next to you you don't say anything I say
something
I took my around go come on man I just
want anyone to know that did me a
fastball it's right I put my AC all the
way on if this guy next to me got it for
me I'll go come on man so they're like
whoa I sat next to a [ __ ] the guy who
fell asleep and started farting and he
was so [ __ ] heavy and just he had
eaten something and he's went
and I was like this [ __ ] guidance oh
god damn it I didn't hear it but I
smelled it I got so mad I was like this
is the worst and then I wake and he puts
his goddamn earphones on he's watching
some terrible sitcom going ha ha ha ha
oh this is the worst
you're the worst sir oh you're the worst
I'll wake him up I'll act like I hit him
on acting like oh I'm sorry I just gotta
get a Cuban check man couldn't breathe
you're gonna die right in front row the
time Jay ripped a fart in the green room
and I was like well we simply can't have
that because there's waiters coming in
and out and now they said I gotta get
ready for a show it smells like a
[ __ ] my buddy can't climb up in here
I go please don't do that
here's no prompt doesn't get on it I
gotta be honest get out yeah I had to
kick Jay sob out of the green room we're
at the earth the little library I'm in
high school there's a girl I loved loved
when I say a locker I didn't like her I
like school of Regional High School love
rates 1917 and we're in the library and
my buddy was the kind of guy who would
fart and loved it and didn't care if I
go hey he just goes to that pad that I
go do it and it's stunk and so Rachel's
there and I go oh my god
and he goes Rachel come here oh no no I
don't know don't come here you know if
the others don't is great so come over
here she's like what [ __ ] just come on
what are you gonna do wait and they like
man she goes what I go no Rachel don't
come here don't Rachel no come here and
she gets into the cloud she goes I swear
to god it wasn't me
cuz yes it was so so funny everything so
[ __ ] up
yes so funny with this right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue Oh what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
okay